this is a very active investigation and
it will be for several hours as police
try to piece together exactly what
happened out here around midnight they
were called here at a baby's Ford Road
about someone who was hit by a car and
when they got here that's when the shots
started to ring out
police say nine people were hit by
bullets two people are dead and five
others were hit by cars as they tried to
run away from the scene there was a very
large crowd out here police say this
started as an impromptu block party and
it began Friday as a Juneteenth
celebration that was sort of just a
continuation into the weekend
emotions understandably high out here
this morning we've seen some of the
large crowds leave the area though there
are hundreds of evidence markers
scattered throughout several crime
scenes in parking lots of different
businesses along Beatty's for the road
crime scene units are out here working
to collect evidence and process the
scenes we had the chance to speak with
current chief deputy Johnny Jennings who
will take over the see MPD Police
Department in September he says what
happened here is a tragedy just
continued on in tonight and police say
they have reason to believe that there
may be more than one shooter involved in
what happened out here they also say the
numbers as far as the people who were
injured they could rise throughout the
morning I'm Anne Wyatt little reporting
in Charlotte